[Music]
who do you see as a favorite in the
other matches well I think all the
materials are going to be very
interesting I would generally say that
the u.s. players are more favorites
there are some players who are quite
strong up in latest time time controls
especially for example he Carl and for
example Wesley I guess Wesley is a
favorite and I would love to see he Cara
playing against Duda see it's the top
match
Wesley's favorite in this match but
David is my friend so I I cannot give
you a clear answer on that match in
blitz definitely Hikaru is the clear
favorite he's proven himself in rockland
boots so often and Duda is a I mean he
has had some very good at robbing and
blitz results but he still hasn't proven
himself in the same way Duda really made
a splash with the world blitz and it
will be interesting and Judah also made
a splash in this just calm thing where
he beat both Christian and Kuryakin I'm
very curious to see what will happen you
know it's like the young gun here it
doesn't do that again
I'm very well-established moving on one
of the best best player in the world
named Cairo it will be very interesting
to see if Duda can keep up that kind of
form against probably as toughest major
opponent yet and well I think that's the
match I'll be looking most closely at as
a spectator although I would put my
money on our camera I don't think that
it's a given that he'll win mine is also
dangerous I mean from for me it's
dangerous for me it's let's say it's
unpredictable linear against Vaseline
I think wrestling is maybe slightly
favorite here Alania Dominguez Perez is
if they work in my opinion because the
end master to party is a great player
but his results in speed chess have been
lately evolved and in classical chess
there two players who have worked
together in the past and both of them
hadn't been so active in terms of
playing recently so they might have to
overcome some rustiness Fabiana in an
Tala obviously Fabian is a favorite and
he's improved a lot and if rapid in
blitz lately he's had a lot of practice
inspiring and I'll say in the project
League when I look at the matchup I
think that Hari Krishna is very solid
player he's always playing e45 and not
he doesn't really play very flashy just
so I think that's probably why Fabiano
picton just to get the chance to uh sort
of play places some more likes all
positions play some of the preparation
that perhaps you didn't show in the
World Championship match and that would
be the main one on it'll also be
interesting to see Sam's match against
Richard because Richard is completely
insane at times he plays very very wild
shots and they're very close the rating
and you know they're doing really good
there's that's grandpa very close to
each other
I can't I wouldn't even be able to pick
a favor in that I think it's basically
just it's awesome that's probably the
one match that I would say is the most
unpredictable where you don't really
know what's gonna happen their styles of
players so dramatically different
I think Shanklin is like a very
classical type of player who make many
mistakes and rapport is one of those
guys who can either play really
brilliantly or or occasionally you can
play badly and collapse
so yeah that's it's a contrast of style
it's naturally its most likely to be a
lot of twists and turns
Sam against Ricci of course Sam is my
friend so I would say Sam is the
favorite in this match
you